das wird eine interessante
auseinandersetzung nächstes jahr bei der
bundestagswahl werden die haben jetzt
gerade das konzept von frau schwesig
gehört da ist dann auch schon der
größere mittelständische betrieb der
zahlen musste jetzt gerade über die
krise gekommen ist ich kann für meine
partei nur eins sagen ich gebe eine
politische garantie ab mit der fdp in
der bundesregierung wird es keine
erhöhung der einkommenssteuer oder der
lohnsteuer für die pflegerin in der
altenpflegeeinrichtung geben für den
facharbeiter nicht für die ingenieure
nicht für den mittelstand und die
industrie eine einzige ausnahme mache
ich die apples und dms und die googles
die auch durch die pandemie massiv an
marktanteil gewonnen haben bei denen
sollten wir unverändert das ziel weiter
verfolgen dass die ihren fairen beitrag
zur finanzierung des gemeinwesens zahlen